[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
we miss taiwan and wish we could be
there in person for computex
so we created taipei city in microsoft
flight sim
and flew in virtually on a geforce rtx
3080.
[Music]
thousands of mods have been created for
flight sim and they've been downloaded
over 10 million times
this mod will be available just after
the keynote
welcome to computex 2021 it's always
great to talk directly to our partners
and this year we have a lot to talk
about
i'm going to kick it off with gaming and
then i'll hand it to manavir das to talk
about ai and our enterprise platforms
so let's get started
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every person born this year will be a
gamer 140 million of them
in fact gen z prefers video gaming as
their favorite entertainment activity
over just about anything
in taiwan two-thirds of the population
plays video games
so it's no surprise that gaming has
transformed into one of the largest and
fastest growing forms of entertainment
and it is here to stay gaming revenue
grew to 180 billion bigger than
cinema music and streaming video
combined
we added 60 million pc gamers to our
ranks
and over 10 000 games were published for
them to enjoy
in april the number of concurrent gamers
on steam was at an all-time high of 27
million
one and a half times that of 2019. like
any sport
people love to watch others play 100
billion hours of gaming content was
viewed on youtube
and more than 430 million people tuned
into esports competitions
and it doesn't stop there minecraft's
open world is estimated to have grown to
four billion square kilometers or eight
times the surface of the planet
valve just announced that the 2021 dota
championship
will feature a 40 million dollar prize
pool
roblox had 42 million daily active users
in the first quarter up 80 percent year
over year
and it's not just about playing there
are 45 million professional
and freelance creators fueling an
explosion in digital content
30 million broadcasters and 75 million
higher ed stem students
all relying on the latest technology to
improve their productivity
and quality of work over the past 20
years we have built g-force into the
number one gaming platform
with one and a half billion gpu shipped
geforce has fueled the growth of pc
gaming
and we continue to delight our customers
with new ways to game and create
our scale and pace of innovation was
only possible by partnering with the
best companies in the world
together we have transformed pc gaming
ten years ago we introduced optimus
dramatically extending battery life in
gaming laptops
all told optimus has saved over 5.8
billion kilowatt hours of energy
enough to power over half a million
homes for a year
max-q changed the way laptops were built
the performance only available in big
heavy gaming machines
was engineered into thin and light
laptops
max-q has shed over 8 million pounds
from gaming laptops sold
g-sync introduced stutter-free gaming
with over
20 trillion buttery smooth pixels now
shipped
once you game with g-sync there is no
turning back
last year we introduced nvidia reflex
which changed the game for esports
competitors
in call of duty war zone alone reflex
gamers have over 50 million wins
finally nvidia studio is our platform
for creators
engineered for the needs of creative
professionals our laptops have
accelerated over 25 billion hours of
content creation
thanks to all of our partners who are
just as excited as we are about
reinventing this market
and are joining us in the next major
leap forward
rtx is a huge reset to computer graphics
a decade in development rtx introduced
the world to real-time ray tracing and
ai for graphics rtx is now available in
a full range of desktops and laptops
in every country from every oem and even
streaming from the cloud
with over a hundred top games and apps
available today
rtx is the new standard for creators and
broadcasters
rtx is accelerating the number one
photography app
the number one video editing app and the
number one broadcast app
for gamers rtx is powering the number
one battle royale
the number one rpg and the number one
best selling game
of all time last month we added
outriders and
call of duty war zone to the list and
today we have
more exciting games to announce dying
1983
is the second game in the dying
franchise from the chinese developer
netcom
it's a japanese inspired horror themed
puzzle game
it's stark and frightening world is
brought to life with rtx ray tracing and
dlss
let's take an exclusive look at dying
1983
with rtx on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tom clancy's rainbow six siege is one of
the most popular esports games in the
world
with over 70 million players worldwide
in march rainbow six gamers gain the
competitive edge of nvidia reflex
today we are announcing that rtx gamers
will get even more performance
with the addition of dlss let's take a
look
new zealand-based developer rocket works
was founded by dean hall
best known as the creator of dayz their
highly anticipated new game
icarus is a stunning multiplayer
survival game
set on a savage alien planet today we
are announcing that icarus will come
alive
with rtx raytrace global illumination
and dlss
when the initial chapter first cohort
launches this fall
let's take a look at some exclusive new
[Music]
footage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
red dead redemption 2 is one of the most
critically acclaimed games of all time
with more than 275 perfect scores
175 game of the year awards and more
than 37 million copies sold to date
we are happy to announce that rockstar
games will be adding dlss
to red dead redemption 2. coming soon
every rtx gamer will see a free boost in
performance
vr is taking off vr game revenue is up
70
on steam in 2020 the installed base of
pc compatible vr headsets
is expected to exceed 30 million in the
next five years
with almost twice the resolution of a
desktop monitor
and unforgiving fps requirements vr is
very demanding on the gpu
and rtx is now coming to vr no man's sky
the popular open world space game
now features dlss vr gamers can soon
play with ultra graphics
at 90 frames per second wrench a
mechanic simulator where you repair
and maintain race cars in vr now
features rtx ray tracing and dlss
and the vr survival shooter into the
radius
adds dlss to boost performance and keep
you immersed in this dystopian world
75 of geforce gamers play esports
we invented nvidia reflex for them the
difference between winning and losing is
a matter of milliseconds
on average reflex reduces system latency
by 20 milliseconds it gets the pc
out of the way so a gamer's real skill
can come to play
and gamers love it more than 90 percent
of them compete with reflex on
today we are announcing even more nvidia
reflex games
gaijin's war thunder the most popular
air land and sea battle arena with over
40 million gamers
naraka bladepoint the highly anticipated
battle royale slasher from 24
entertainment
in the last closed beta it broke into
steam's top five games played
tencent games crossfire hd is a
remastered version of the original
with over 560 million gamers in china
and escape from tarkov the intense
survival shooter from battlestate games
is one of the top 10 most played
competitive shooters
coming soon 12 of the top 15 competitive
shooters will feature nvidia reflex
let's take a look at reflex in escape
from tarkov
[Music]
for serious competitors reducing system
latency starts by measuring it
from end to end this requires an
ecosystem of partners
last year we introduced the reflex
latency analyzer
a measurement tool built directly into
gaming monitors
today we are adding lenovo viewsonic and
evga
13 partners are offering a total of 15
monitors
and 21 compatible mice now more gamers
can simply plug a mouse into the monitor
and accurately measure end-to-end
latency from click
to photon almost 10 years ago we
introduced our kepler architecture
and created a new class of laptops for
gamers
while the market reception was great
these laptops were large
bulky and had limited battery life more
transportable than portable
in 2016 we introduced the pascal
architecture
and max-q technology a full system
design approach
to bringing high performance to thin and
light laptops
performance increased by over 4x and for
the first time
high performance gaming laptops were
less than 20 millimeters thick
this year we launched ampere our second
generation rtx
it featured our third generation max q
and delivered twice the performance of
pascal
but the real magic is dlss
gamers have taken notice and geforce
laptops are the fastest growing gaming
platform
laptops are a marvel of engineering no
effort is spared to deliver the highest
performance
in a thin and light device in laptop
design
system power determines everything
including performance
battery life thinness and acoustics what
if you could get a massive boost in
gaming performance
without expending any more power let's
say you are playing control
at 47 frames per second at 1440p
the gpu is rendering almost 4 million
pixels
and drawing 80 watts of power nvidia
dlss uses ai powered tensor cores
to boost frame rates with dlss the gpu
only needs to render a fraction of the
pixels
and then uses ai to complete the frame
the result is an image just as beautiful
as native 1440p
and you get one and a half to two times
the performance at the same power
alienware was one of our earliest
partners designing high-performance
geforce pcs for gamers
for the past two years we've been
working together to create an
amazing new laptop today we're
announcing the alienware x15
an ultra-thin geforce rtx 3080 laptop
powered by max-q technologies including
dynamic boost
whisper mode and advanced optimus and
featuring a 1440p display
it's the world's most powerful sub 16
millimeter
15 inch gaming laptop tune into the
alienware update event on june 1st to
learn more
this year brought a record launch for
rtx laptops
with over 140 models from every oem
starting at 799 and featuring max q
there is now an rtx laptop for every
gamer
we developed nvidia studio to address
the growing needs of 3d designers
video editors and photographers these
are specially configured systems
optimized and tested for creator
workflows and supported with a monthly
cadence of studio drivers
today we are announcing new studio
laptops from hp and acer
the 14 inch hp envy brings the
capabilities of rtx
to an ultra portable laptop great for
students and creators on the go
the new acer concept d offers a variety
of traditional clamshell options
and an easel sketchboard design to give
creators
even more flexibility gaming has been an
inspiration to digital creators and
artists for decades
machinima an art form started in the 90s
uses real-time 3d technologies with game
assets
visual effects and character animation
to create
short humorous clips or full-length
movies
for these artists we created omniverse
machinima
making it easy to produce cinematic
animated stories
with advanced real-time ray tracing nai
users import their own game assets or
draw from our growing library
they can then apply advanced physics
effects like destruction or fire
with nvidia's blast and flow animate
movements
using only a webcam with wrenches ai
pose
and use simple audio tracks to animate
character faces
with audio to face the final scenes are
rendered in the omniverse rtx renderer
machinima was just released in beta let
me show you how you can create your own
masterpiece
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa look at me i'm in the omniverse
what are you doing in my kitchen
rtx has been a huge success and today we
are announcing
a new addition to the family the geforce
rtx 3080 ti
is our new flagship gaming gpu based on
ampere with second generation rt cores
and third generation tensor cores
ampere is our greatest generational leap
[Music]
ever
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the 80 tie class of gpus represents the
best of our gaming lineup
the gtx 1080 tie released in 2017
could tackle all the games of its time
but this well-loved gpu
simply can't keep up with the demands of
modern games
the rtx 2080 tie was introduced as the
only way to play in 4k
with rtx on but the production value of
games continues to march forward
new titles like cyberpunk 2077 and
watchdog's legion
have elevated realism demanding even
more of the gpu
the rtx 3080 ti is one and a half times
faster than its predecessor
and tears through the latest games with
all the settings cranked up
the rtx 3080 tie is a powerful gpu
with 34 shader teraflops 67
rt teraflops and 273 tensor teraflops
it comes equipped with 12 gigabytes of
ultra fast
g6x memory and a 384 bit memory
interface
availability will begin on june 3rd
starting at 11.99
to show you what this beast can do we
have a special announcement
doom is a storied franchise known by a
generation of gamers for pushing the
boundaries of speed
power and visual effects do maternal
the latest in the series takes this even
further
based on the id tech 7 engine it's
blistering fast
and beautiful today we're announcing do
maternal
is adopting rtx ray tracing and dlss
here is a first look at doom eternal
with ray tracing
at 4k running on a 3080 tie
[Music]
[Music]
and that's not all the rtx 3070 quickly
became our most popular ampere gpu
now we're adding a tie to this class of
geforce with more cores and super fast
g6x memory
today we're announcing the all-new rtx
3070 tie
it's one and a half times faster than a
2070 super
and availability will begin on june 10th
starting at 5.99
thanks everyone for your time before i
hand it off to manaver let me summarize
gaming is transforming entertainment and
rtx is changing everything
not just for gamers but for 150 million
creators
broadcasters and students with over a
hundred of the top games and creative
apps accelerated
rtx is the new standard geforce laptops
are the fastest growing gaming platform
now fueled top to bottom by rtx
third generation max q and the
performance boosting magic of dlss
and studio specially designed for
creators extends their reach
beyond gaming finally the rtx desktop
family just got better with our new
flagship gaming gpu
the geforce rtx 3080 ti and the geforce
rtx 3070 ti
every person born today is a gamer we
have an amazing future ahead and we look
forward to building it with all of you
and here to tell you how we're putting
ai into the hands of every company
is matavir das head of enterprise
computing
thank you jeff and thank you everyone
for joining us today
our journey at nvidia began with gaming
but today we are also the driver of the
most powerful technology
force of our time artificial
intelligence
let's take a look at just some of the
ways in which ai
powered by nvidia is improving our world
[Music]
[Music]
i am a creator
[Music]
blending art and technology
to immerse our senses
i am a healer
helping us take the next step
and see what's possible
i am a pioneer
finding life-saving answers
and pushing the edge to the outer limits
i am a guardian
defending our oceans
and the magnificent creatures that call
them home
i am a protector
[Music]
helping the earth breathe easier
and watching over it for generations to
come
[Music]
i am a storyteller
giving emotion to words
and bringing them to life
i am even the composer of the music
[Music]
[Applause]
i am a.i brought to life by nvidia
deep learning and brilliant minds
everywhere
and that was just a hint of what ai can
do
taiwan has always been a very special
place for nvidia
from system builders and solution
providers to universities in the
government
all have partnered with us on behalf of
jensen and nvidia
thank you to all of our many friends in
taiwan who have worked alongside us
to enable these amazing ai breakthroughs
together we have laid the foundation for
a new computing model
based on ai software that writes
software
this foundation includes gpus deployed
in the cloud and in data centers
ai software and sdks tailored to the
world's
largest industries and an ecosystem of
startups and developers
now it's time to build the house on top
of this foundation
it is time to democratize ai by bringing
its transformative power
to every company and its customers there
are three
fundamental shifts that will bring ai to
every company
the first shift is that every
application used by any company
will be infused with ai ai is
essentially
a two-step process first a rich set of
existing data
and known outcomes from that data are
used to train a model
then the model is applied to fresh data
to make fresh judgments
the model is effectively a piece of
software that can be embedded into any
application as the application runs
it queries the model to make judgments
giving it intelligence
as new data becomes available the model
is retrained and improved
automatically making the application
better without human developers having
to create a new version
a great example of this infusion of ai
is in microsoft office
the world's most popular productivity
application
microsoft is adding smart experiences
such as smart grammar correction
q a and text prediction to office
with nvidia gpus microsoft was able to
improve responsiveness to less than
one-fifth of a second
enabling real-time grammar correction
and at one-third the cost of the same
work
on cpus going forward
every application will have to be built
in this way or be left behind
now this is not the first time we've
seen this kind of shift
for example consider the introduction of
the graphical user interface
the gui once the transformative value of
gui became evident
every command line application had to
adopt gui
or be left behind in the same way
every application will need to be
infused with ai
and all of these applications will need
the most performant
power efficient and cost effective
systems to run on
regardless of form factor location from
edge to cloud
every system will need a gpu
the second shift is that every data
center used by any company
will be infused with ai computing is
increasingly being driven by
large amounts of data neither the data
nor the computation done on it can fit
on one server
therefore the flow of data through the
network becomes crucial
to both the capability and the security
of the data center
a new kind of hardware is needed that
sits on the data path
and intelligently optimizes inspects
and protects the data and protects the
applications from one another
this new hardware is the data processing
unit
or dpu every server
will need a dpu the third shift
is that the life cycle of every product
produced by any company
will be optimized by ai consider the
very common and old-fashioned example of
soap
yes so going forward
a soap company will design and tailor
its soap product portfolio
by analyzing rich data on the usage and
experience of the customer base
the soap manufacturing process will be
automated and optimized with ai
customers who use soap pretty much the
entire population of the world
will be engaged socially and sold to
online
smart soap dispensers will track usage
and automatically order refills
and all the data from the customer
experience will be fed back
to guide the design and supply chain of
the soap
this soap company and every other
company will need a new form of i.t
and it infrastructure to operate the ai
optimized life cycle of its product
these are fundamental shifts that will
require massive amounts of accelerated
computing
now let's talk about how you can build
on the technology foundation of nvidia
to make this a reality how you can
democratize
ai we start with the hard way
nvidia dgx is the instrument of ai
since its launch in 2016 dgx has been
used by companies across
industries at the forefront of ai
the reason for this is that dgx was
designed from the ground up
as the optimal system for ai every
component
and every interconnect was designed or
chosen with great care
and today dgx incorporates learnings
from hundreds of millions of hours of
usage
on thousands of systems across the
planet
the pinnacle of ai capability is the dgx
superpod
where multiple dgxs are clustered
together and tuned for ai
based on all of nvidia's learnings so
the first step to democratization
is to make this best of breed machine
more accessible
and more obtainable to make it more
accessible
we are providing a software stack called
base command platform
using kubernetes this software allows
administrators to share this powerful
supercomputer
across an organization of data
scientists and a mix of workloads
it provides users with a simple
interface for ai
and it allows organizations to
understand and optimize
their usage of this valuable equipment
we have been using base command within
nvidia for many years
sharing superpods across thousands of
data scientists
who have run over a million jobs to make
it more obtainable
we are introducing a subscription model
for superpod
customers can now experience the
capability of a super pod
or a smaller part of a super pod for
months at a time
this is a hosted offering in which
nvidia will manage the infrastructure
reducing the operational burden on
customers
the offering includes powerful all-flash
storage and integrated data management
from netapp
the pioneer of enterprise nas storage
netapp is synonymous with enterprise
great storage with over 38 000 customers
today
on premises and in the cloud the
subscription model is in early access
now
for example adobe is already using the
infrastructure to train stylegan
a powerful image generation ai the model
will open up for paid access
this summer with this offering we expect
that many more customers
will be able to experience the unique
capability of a super pod
without the upfront investment from
there they can graduate to more
permanent infrastructure at scale
either their own super pod or in the
public cloud
speaking of the cloud for some time now
we have worked with our cloud partners
to offer powerful gpu instances in the
cloud
leveraging the internal components of
dgx
we are proud to announce today that
amazon and google are working with us
to enable base command platform for
clusters formed from these cloud
instances this work offers the promise
of a true hybrid ai experience for
customers
write once run anywhere but even as we
democratize access to dgx
the larger objective is to decompose dgx
into its smallest ai optimized parts
so that system manufacturers can compose
those parts into different form factors
for
different scenarios while adding unique
value-add capabilities
for their customers first we productize
the gpu board
that combines multiple gpus into a
tightly interconnected computing fabric
this is hgx then
we offered the core gpu from the board
as a stand-alone pcie card
this is the a100 now we have further
broken down the a100
into smaller form factor gpus such as
the a30
that draw less power and are lower cost
while still providing powerful
acceleration
and finally we have productized the same
bluefield 2 dpu
that is inside dgx superpod now usable
in any server with this we have now
enabled a complete ecosystem of form
factors
from supercomputers to pizzabox servers
workstations and edge devices these form
factors can be used in a variety of
scenarios
from compute to graphics to virtual
desktops
to data center infrastructure all made
better by ai
hgx boards are the engine of
supercomputing
a100 and 830 are optimized for compute
a40 and a10 are best for a mix of
compute and graphics
and a16 combines multiple small gpus
into a great form factor
for vdi in order to help system
manufacturers create ai optimized
designs
and to ensure that the systems can be
relied on by customers
we created nvidia certified a program
for servers that incorporate gpu
acceleration
nvidia certified provides blueprints for
system design
as well as test suites so that system
manufacturers can validate their designs
today we are announcing the expansion of
nvidia certified
to systems with nvidia bluefield dpus
going forward the dpu will be an
essential component of
every server in the data center and at
the edge
this is because as shown in the diagram
the dpu offloads
accelerates and secures functions that
must otherwise be performed by the host
cpu
last year we announced bluefield 2 our
state-of-the-art dpu
nvidia is working closely with vmware to
use bluefield 2 as the host for the esxi
hypervisor
as part of project monterey this year we
released the first version of doka
the sdk of bluefield we expect that doka
will do for the dpu
what cuda has done for the gpu enabling
millions of developers with a long
lasting consistent sdk
that they can use from one generation of
bluefield
to the next and we are especially
pleased to announce
that the world system manufacturers are
joining us in the dpo journey
by producing state-of-the-art mainstream
servers
accelerated by nvidia bluefield 2. three
of these companies are right here in
taiwan
asus gigabyte and qanta
bluefield 2 is especially well suited to
inspecting the network for security
breaches
the typical approach is to run an agent
on the host cpu
this approach consumes host cpu cycles
and handles only a narrow window of the
network traffic
bluefield 2 allows full inspection with
no host cpu overhead
nvidia has created a software platform
called morpheus
that uses the bluefield 2 and ai to
automatically detect
and address security breaches today
we are announcing that red hat is
working with nvidia to provide morpheus
developer kits for
both openshift and red hat enterprise
linux or rel for short
rel is the most commonly used version of
commercial linux
in enterprise data centers today cyber
security companies
will now be able to use morpheus on rel
and openshift to bring advanced security
to every enterprise data center but this
journey is just beginning
we are already working on bluefield
three 22 billion
transistors the first 400 gigabits per
second networking chip
16 arm cpu cores to run the entire
virtualization software stack
bluefield 3 takes security to a whole
new level fully offloading and
accelerating ipsec
tls cryptography secret key management
and regular expression processing
whereas bluefield 2
offloaded an equivalent of 30 cpu cores
it would take
300 cpu cores to secure offload and
accelerate the networking traffic at 400
gbps
this is a 10x leap in performance
bluefield 3 the next generation
but the same doca sdk today
we are also announcing the expansion of
nvidia certified
to accelerated systems with arm-based
host cpus
as the gpu and dpu accelerators take on
more of the compute workload for ai
it becomes useful to view the host cpu
as an
orchestrator more so than as the compute
engine
energy efficient arm cpus are well
suited to this task
and the open licensing model of arm
inspires innovators to create products
around it
an exemplar of this approach is nvidia's
own arm-based
grace cpu which will be available in
2023.
grace is purpose-built for accelerated
computing applications such as ai that
process
large amounts of data
two years ago we announced that we were
bringing cuda
to arm simplifying the development of ai
and hpc applications
on arm today along with our partner
taiwan-based gigabyte we are happy to
announce a dev kit
this dev kit can be used by application
developers to prepare their gpu
accelerated apps
for arm so there it is
democratizing the hardware for ai with a
wide range
of accelerators turned into myriad form
factors
by a broad ecosystem of system builders
103 different server and workstation
form factors
from 16 different system builders
more every day now let's turn to the
software
of ai every ai workflow
can be thought of as a four-step process
in a loop
the first step is to take a large amount
of unstructured data
and prepare it by extracting and
organizing
its features the second step is to use
the prepared data to train the models
in many cases the models are then
validated or simulated
before being used in production or in
the physical world
and finally the actual use of the models
which in turn generates more data that
is then fed back to the process
this is the recipe of ai
over the years nvidia has applied this
recipe
to create application frameworks for a
variety of use cases
including conversational ai drug
discovery
self-driving cars robotics virtual
collaboration
and recommender systems the engine of
the internet
these frameworks help companies jump
start their adoption of ai
for example nvidia clara is our
application framework for ai powered
healthcare
it includes sdks and reference
applications for drug discovery
smart hospitals medical imaging and
genomic analysis
one customer that uses clara is
astrazeneca
with clara they created an ai model for
generating new drug candidates that
target a given disease
while maximizing safety this method has
seen recent success
with in silicon medicine using ai to
find a new drug in
less than two years companies across the
world
are using these ai workflows from nvidia
to improve their businesses
and to help their customers a great
example from taiwan
is tsmc we all know tsmc as a giant of
the technology ecosystem
producing millions of wafers every year
for semiconductor and technology
companies across the planet
analysts have referred to tsmc as the
hope diamond
of the semiconductor industry in fact
nvidia itself
is a very large partner of dsmc
proactively identifying defective
materials
and classifying them to minimize further
defects is a critical aspect of the chip
production process
engineers at tsmc have developed an ai
powered system
to automate inspection and defect
classification
their system is 10 times faster and more
accurate
compared to the previous human method
all of these ai workflows
are built from the same essential
software libraries and toolkits
now we have brought all these components
together
as nvidia ai enterprise a coherent
optimized certified and supported
software platform
for ai nvidia air enterprise
is fully integrated with vmware vsphere
the de facto standard of enterprise
computing
it is licensed priced and supported in
the same way as vsphere
for a consistent experience and it all
runs on nvidia certified servers
mainstream volume servers that are
constantly racked into enterprise data
centers
71 different servers from 16 vendors
and more every day but the components of
nvidia ai
are useful for more than ai nvidia ai
includes rapids
a set of libraries that accelerate
machine learning on gpus
the same libraries can also accelerate
the core engines of big data processing
such as apache spark cloudera is the de
facto provider of apache spark
to enterprise data centers around the
world with over five
exabytes of data under management as the
technology landscape has changed
cloudera has developed cloudera data
platform
a hybrid data cloud platform that brings
customers forward to new
technology without having to reinvent
their big data pipelines
as we speak the 2000 customers of
cloudera
are migrating to cloudera data platform
we are pleased to say that nvidia and
cloudera have partnered
to add transparent gpu acceleration
using nvidia rapids
a fully integrated solution from
cloudera will be available starting this
summer
with the release of cdp version 717
customers do not need to understand
rapids
or change their workflows in any way in
order to obtain the benefits of this gpu
acceleration
an example of an early customer is the
united states
internal revenue service with zero
changes to their fraud detection
workflow
they were able to obtain three times the
performance
simply by adding gpus to their
mainstream big data servers
this performance improvement translated
to half the cost of ownership
for the same workload but even as the
world is transformed by ai
another shift is underway amplified by
the global pandemic
it is becoming more and more important
for virtual teams of people in different
locations
to collaborate in real time this is
especially true for 3d workflows
from visualizing architecture to
creating photorealistic content for
games and movies
to simulating physically accurate worlds
this is a domain
nvidia is very familiar with and the
same gpus and systems we talked about in
the democratization of ai
are in fact the ideal foundation on
which to build a platform for real-time
collaboration
and simulation of 3d designs this
is nvidia omniverse omniverse makes it
easy
for teams to collaboratively design and
simulate
in 3d we built omniverse with open
standards
based on pixar's usd a powerful file
framework and scene description language
with open standards omniverse enables
teams to connect and work across
multiple design applications
or asset libraries in real time and
at the highest fidelity just as we did
with ai
we have put the functionality of
omniverse into an enterprise-grade
software platform
nvidia omniverse enterprise omniverse
enterprise can run on any nvidia rtx
powered infrastructure
from professional laptops to
workstations to gpu accelerated
virtualized or bare metal servers
we are excited to partner with leading
global system providers
who will offer nvidia omniverse
enterprise later this year
starting at just fourteen thousand
dollars per year per company
the omniverse subscription comes with
connectors which are plugins for the
world's most important third-party
design applications
allowing multiple designers and creators
to use their preferred tools
while simultaneously editing a scene
together
companies around the world and across
industries are already using omniverse
to collaborate in amazing ways
let's see how omniverse is ushering in a
new era
of virtual worlds
[Music]
oh
[Music]
where are you from misty i'm from a
place called omniverse
[Music]
so there you have it it is time to put
accelerated computing to use
for every company this is a giant
opportunity
and responsibility for all of us
what we've talked about today are three
essential
ingredients built by nvidia the hardware
foundation
from which to build any system the
software platform
for artificial intelligence the software
platform
for collaborative design together we can
use these three ingredients
to transform every company and yet
this is the same hardware and software
technology that is at the heart of
geforce
the gaming gpu which is where it all
began
i'll close with a simple thank you on
behalf of my co-presenter jeff fisher
our ceo jensen wong and all of nvidia
thank you thank you for joining us today
thank you for being with us every step
of the way
and thank you for continuing forward
with us
on this amazing journey
you